mark first reaction we got the shot of
you reacting on the phone and seeing it
first reaction and thought when you
learned that the seasons been suspended
this is crazy this can't be true I mean
it's not within the realm of
possibilities it's just to seem more
like out of a movie than reality when
you woke up this morning knowing
everything you did knowing that the call
was going to happen with the Board of
Governors what did you expect from today
and some of the steps next thing about
it is we're not I'm not an expert on
lockers trying to be an expert and the
NBA was our plan here was to defer to
the NBA I mean they have people who
specialize in this and they're talking
to the the CDC the Health Organization
you know HHS so I don't want to pretend
and try to fake it you know so we were
just gonna defer to the NBA how do you
assess the decision I mean I trust Adam
I mean you know what it's really not
about basketball their money I mean
literally if if this thing is just
exploding to the point where you know
all of a sudden players and others have
had you think about your family you know
you want to really make sure you're
doing this the right way
you know because now it's much more
personal and you've seen what's
happening in other countries but just
the whole idea that it's come disclosed
and potentially a couple players have it
just stunning isn't the right word I
mean just crazy what concerns do you
have right now for your team
it's not about team it's just about you
know the country and life in general you
know I mean we've got we've got the
pieces in place I'm concerned about that
you know now that we're not playing
games what about all the people who work
here on an hourly basis you know we put
these won't put together a program for
them you know there's just so many
things that go through your head right
it's hard to know you know talking to
some of the guys who are playing on the
bench it's like look I don't think you
guys going to be able to leave town it's
not like okay this is like a lockout
time and just go enjoy and we'll figure
it out and come say no I mean the whole
idea is the only way and I'm guessing
here
have any control over to making sure our
players are healthy is that we know what
they're where they're at who they're
working with you know and who they're
dealing with
how will where is your team right now of
what's happening I'm pretty sure
everybody's aware at this one you know I
mean guys were talking about it on the
bench
except for the guys in the game itself
and look the guy's going to get yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
this is much bigger than just the NBA
this hopefully will get the CC double
when we talk about getting the season
back on track
that means all this got worked out right
that that maybe we understand more about
it and it'll be you know less of an
issue for the entire touch of the entire
world so that's really what's most
important I mean I walked over to my
wife is like can we send our kids to
school tomorrow you know is it that big
and again you know
it's like out of a movie not even real
we really appreciate the time and you
sharing your thoughts on what's this
afternoon evolving situation now just
everybody's own conclusion
you know don't you
you know do what's right for your
families that's Ralphie
and to you too we appreciate your mark
we'll come back from down